[Music]
all right let's go to sarah in kansas
city sarah hey what's going on
hey how are you i am rocking onto the
brick of dawn how about you
doing good awesome so what's up
okay so i wrote it down so i could be
direct
um
so i am one of three sisters um
short story like we were homeschooled
elementary
uh my dad was a pastor when we were
younger so we grew up in the church okay
and right now we're trying to deal with
my parents basically was it a good grow
up in the church experience sometimes
that means one of two things like it was
great or
we're dealing with all kinds of family
trauma
uh yeah not great
[Laughter]
it was awful um okay so
great himalayan i don't want to like
completely put it down
hey as a good preacher's kid you're able
to loop it around and make it sort of
your fault but they were great
they just hit us with sticks a couple of
times a week it wasn't okay good job way
to go so we'll get that's a whole other
call someday i think so um talk to me
about your three sisters and you're
dealing with your parents so what's up
um so basically like especially with
covid
it's just hard to communicate because
when we do try to communicate with them
like our concerns
it comes back it's the end of days it's
i get a bible verse i get a dream i get
a prophecy you know what i mean sweet
where's just like
that's kind of how it's always been to a
point good so it's like
and just to put it out there my oldest
sister is in healthcare i mean both of
them are i'm in the restaurant industry
so we see things like first hand
correct
where they're in a small town
have no diversity
you know
so there's just a way that
they see what they see on the internet
and in their small community y'all are
seeing things on the front lines
and
like literally my sister is intubating
people okay so there's a um like an
experiential component to this and then
there is mom and dad just being mom and
dad and now they have gone into end
times
realms is that fair yes
okay and so how how can i help you you
ask me what what do y'all do
so basically
like my sister tried to like have a good
discussion but it just ends up blowing
up of course and i always just avoid the
conflict
okay but it's you know like
are you supposed to
like dive in or do you just dance around
it and talk about the weather yes
okay so
the way i deal with these kind of
conversations is i wait to be invited in
which i never am
and
or i that's not true i am invited in for
a living but with my close friends and
family they know how i think about
things and i know how they think about
things and so
um
the only thing you can do is either a
completely avoid them draw boundaries
and say we i refuse to have this
conversation with you
b
um
or yeah number two you can
just try to connect
meaning i know what i'm gonna get with
this this and this and i'm gonna still
go have a cup of coffee anyway i'm gonna
still
take mom out for dinner or whatever
not with the goal of trying to convert
anybody or try to win anybody but just
try to
be connected that's it i mean you can't
change their mind they've been this way
for their your whole life
yeah right and then you throw
um end times
that's the college i mean you throw that
i mean
there's nothing you can do to change
anybody's mind here the question you
have to have is
is it hurting you to be in their
presence and if it is you have to make a
decision on on what your boundaries are
going to be there or
are you just going to wade into it and
love mom and dad and roll your eyes and
go about your day
and i think that's hard i mean that's
kind of what i was thinking
but it's hard to because we all live far
away that's right that's right you can't
just go have coffee or you know what i
mean
phone calls but it's
always yeah yeah and
and at some point you have to decide if
they don't want to talk to you
um if they don't want to connect with
you you're going to have to decide to
grieve that because that really hurts
and at some point there's still that
magical fairyland thinking that they're
gonna one day go you know what we're so
your childhood we're sorry for that you
know what like um we've got different
opinions now and we read this article
and holy smokes were we off right and at
some point the three sisters y'all have
to come to the terms that's never going
to happen
yeah and that is a hard
gut-wrenching tearful
realization
and this is another question i have too
is
so
you know like my dad's great
but like my mom she she wants more
out of our relationship yeah you know
but she's very loyal to my dad so it's
kind of like
i feel like she's asking for more
yeah the hard part here is she's a
grown-up and she can get more if she
wants it
yeah she wants you to give more not her
and so she's asking you to carry the
bulk of this relationship and that is an
unfair request from a parent to their
child
okay
you can though say i would love to start
um communicating more i can't have the
code conversation anymore
and i love hearing about your faith
journey mom i don't want to hear any
more about end times
and i think that's a
we did that this year for my family and
my family is all a bunch of nerds my
family's all way smarter than me and
um we're all
you can't ima i'm the quiet one at the
dinner table but that way and we should
tell you how our how fun and exciting
our thanksgivings and christmases are
they're hilarious we laugh we get all
loud with each other um but there's a
bunch of really smart people sitting on
our table and
um we sent mike my we sent out an email
this year no politics and because you
know in december and november was right
before the election no politics and no
no covey talk
and we just sent that out and everybody
in our family abided by it was awesome
but we just called it out now i've got
really extraordinary parents i got real
extraordinary in-laws i'll i will say
that because i know there are some of my
friends who did that their parents would
be like oh you can't tell me what to
talk about but we just said hey let's
don't do that and
all everybody was great
and so it's just kind of saying hey
that's going to be our boundary i don't
want my kids listening to us fighting i
don't want all these crazy arguments i
don't want to be scrolling the internets
trying to come up with arguments to
let's just hang out
right just go fishing or go for a walk
can we just like do that can we talk
about the weather can we talk about
boyfriends and husbands and weird
girlfriends you know and can we just do
that tell old stories we play games and
that's where we focused on and ended up
being
really great trips all around
so i need to find more games
i mean i don't know what works in your
phrase is my go-to i don't know yes come
up with a different game you all can do
better than that
um we did something to silly and we got
grandkids so it makes it easier right
but we did something as silly as um zoom
charades which were oh my parents were
all in it was a riot dude
hey i mean i like we laughed so hard
watching my parents they were in
separate rooms on different computers
doing
it was a riot my kids were dying left
all of us were having a blast
um we did all kinds of things like that
and um
we all want another thing hey this is a
great idea is to read a book together
all four of you your sisters and your
mom that's just fiction
there's my wife has a like a a text list
with her mom and some of the cousins of
her cousins and they just read like
fiction books and it's a blast they are
loving it everyone recommends something
but it's something that not political
not non not
you know it's just like a book right
it's like a fun book and they are loving
it and then i'm gonna start that with my
dad like we're gonna so there's all
kinds of things like that you can do
that's just being creative saying how
can we connect or we're going to all
listen to this one cd because you know
where it's 1844 or an old record or
whatever and then we're going to say
we're going to all get on a call and see
if we liked it or not but it's you being
creative saying i'm going to reconnect
this way but i think it starts with you
having a boundary saying hey i want to
reconnect with you so much mom
but we're not talking about these things
it hurts my heart hurts your heart we're
going to agree to not do that so let's
start talking about books and music i
got a great new book let's all read it
i'll even buy the first one and mail it
out to all three of my sisters and to
you and we'll start there right so yes
you getting creative going that away um
and
lean into it man but it's not your job
to carry that friendship and that
relationship um
she's a grown adult too right thank you
so so much for that call i know there
are millions of people going through
that challenge right now
but
you can't change your mind
you can't heal her you can't tell her
that one thing and she's gonna go oh
yeah you can just love her
warts and all